the new policies that Alberta Premier
Danielle Smith says support Children and
Youth as they grow into adults has
triggered some division the UCP
government's policy on sex education and
parental rights includes significant
changes among the changes are minors
under the age of 15 will now require
parental notification and consent for
them to change their pronouns in school
for 16 and 17 year-olds parents won't
have to give sent but the parents must
be notified in her video address Premier
Smith also expressed concern over
children biologically altering their own
bodies saying it poses a risk to
Children's Futures that she is not
comfortable allowing for minors age 17
and under top and bottom gender
reassignment surgeries will not be
permitted for children age 15 and under
puberty blockers and hormone therapies
for the purpose of gender reassignment
or affirmation will also not be
permitted with the exception of those
who've already commenced their treatment
at this time minors age 16 and 17 will
be permitted to commence hormone
therapies for gender reassignment and
affirmation purposes so long as they are
deemed mature enough to make these
decisions and have parental physici and
psychologist approval one
lgbtq2 Advocate we spoke with saying
this is grim for the future of the
province it's a dark day for albertans
in this province who are transgender
this will irrevocably harm youth in this
in this province um I would not be
surprised if there are trans youth who
are forced to flee as refugees away from
Alberta because of this horribly
transphobic policy this is not rooted in
medical science this is not rooted in
empirical studies this is rooted in what
Danielle Smith believes while reaction
continues to pour in on social media
political analysts also weighing in
she's trying to accomplish here is to
stand up um for the rights of
lgbtq2s people as she has done uh in her
past as well but then at the same time
trying to respect parental rights and
and in the process restrict the choices
that some students in school might
previously have had the premier also
said topics around gender identity
sexual orientation or human sexuality
for all grades will need ministerial
approval to ensure its age appropriate
the premier adding she plans to attract
Physicians and surgeons who specialize
in transgender healthc care needs she
will be officially presenting these
policies in a media conference Thursday
afternoon on social media NDP opposition
leader Rachel notley told two spirit and
trans albertans there are many Alberton
standing with them against hate not Le
says new Democrats will have more to say
on Thursday AA sidu Global
News